[Music]
this is the Ducati 1199 Panigale s the
fastest production motorcycle in
important and this is me riding
oh here we go it's getting on the gas
just forget everything you know about
speech any of the smallest input you
make just instantly translate some
movement on the bike so how does a
novice like me handle a bike like this
well computers of course it's good a
nice as the technology that's out there
for the street bike of today was only on
the racetrack it kind of like five ten
years ago ABS traction control all of
these engine management advances and now
they're putting that into the street
bike while technically street-legal with
turn signals mirrors and the added
safety of a computer that corrects
novice mistakes this bikes 195
horsepower engine is not really suitable
for the daily commute cycle is to build
one of the lightest motorcycle
production bike on the market the
engineer were very excited they got a
chance to start from scratch we built a
new engine the new chassis it's designed
in every detail so what makes this the
world's fastest production motorcycle I
think you have to take three things into
consideration that would be aerodynamics
horsepower and torque and then of course
extreme weight reduction
the engine on this motorcycle is a
stressed member meaning that we've got a
monocoque frame at the beginning and
connects to the motor and the motor
connects to the rear of the bike so
there's not a perimeter frame around it
to make the bike wider now what that
does is it really gives the bike a lot
of rigidity as well it's a very stiff
motorcycle and now well I was the rider
a lot of feeling a lot of feedback he's
very outgoing with girls where you want
it to go it's seriously unnerving to
ride this thing and I'm not just being
obvious the 1199 is fast
[Music]